[Applaudissements]
double sfm à lui on s'en fout mais vous
adorez kolontar valises
merci c'est moi de vous avoir dérangé
car l'autre à la une humeur de chien du
bâton de vous ça ne rigole pas du tout
merci en tout cas merci de ta ça fait
vraiment plaisir de bosser avec vous
alors
[Applaudissements]
à
on a perdu vous votre meyrals vous
appelez moi même surtout elle me
convoque parce qu'on habite dans le même
immeuble
ah ouais le soir alors jouer alors vous
connaissez quoi c'est la dynastie vénaux
venez là bas où elle habite sa banlieue
ces gens ya un immeuble il ya marqué v12
la maman sa graine papa au quatrième les
cousins incroyable tu peux venir au
cinquième maman tu appelles lapidation
mais david ou quoi sert elle me combat
quand j'ai déconné là bas je vais dans
son aparté elle m'engage à vous dit quoi
tu étais trop gros ce soir tu étais trop
vulgaire territoire de gueuler et à rien
de crier trop fort non
en tout cas regarde l'émission ça fait
plaisir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
quelques mois déjà je veux commencer par
une phrase c'est que les gens qui
gagnent toujours et moi je sais que vous
êtes un vrai gentil et vous avez
vraiment été blessé et est ce que je
voulais dire aussi c'est qu'à un moment
donné enfin qui est aussi sincère que
vous à l'antenne je pense personne et ça
je pense que c'est une grande qualité
vous avez beaucoup beaucoup de défauts
mais c'est une très belle qualité
beaucoup de familles connaissent elle
m'a dit quand même un petit merci d'être
là bien sûr qu haïti tahiti parce que
dans un instant nous recevrons miss
france 2
mais comme des poux c'est 2018 2019 a
bien su rassurer et de l'année on maudit
2019 je sais très bien qu'on en 2010 on
a dit bon allez la météo en 2018 miss
france
alors c'est 2019 alors c'est comme le
beaujolais d'accord d'accord c'est juste
un peu logique c'est juste un peu
logique et bon vous savez que vous allez
sortira plus